في دعوه الى السلام العالمي اعلن الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي قبل نهائي كاس العالم عن
مبادره لتنظيم قمه عالميه توحد كل العالم
حول صيغه سلام هذا الشتاء
الى السلام اكثر من اي وقت اخر لقد قدمنا
معادله السلام للعالم في معادله عادله
تماما لانه لا يوجد ابطالا في الحرب لا
يمكن ان يكون هناك تعادل ذلك
دعوه السلام لهذه تاتي في الوقت الذي
تستمر فيه الضربات الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه مخموطه التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
80 الف نسمه والتي لم يبقى فيها سوى اقل
من 12000 اصبحت رمزا للحرب الطاحنه التي
تدور على طول الجزء الاكبر من الجبهه
الشرقيه خدمه الاطفاء المحليه قالت انه مع
تكرار استهداف الضربات الروسيه للمواقع
نفسها اصبحت مكافحه الحرائق تحديا متزايده
99% من الحرائق مرتبطه بالقصف لم يتبقى
الكثير من الناس
الجنوبيه
جنت 54 هجوما على منطقه خرسا في اليوم
السابق ما اسفر عن قتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه
سته اخرين اما في العا تكييف وبعد احدث
موجه من الضربات الجويه الروسيه التي
استهدفت البنيه التحتيه الحيويه فقد
استئنفت الخدمات الاساسيه وعدد الكهرباء
الى ما يقاربوا من سته ملايين شخص في
البلاد كما اعيد توصيل واندا ذات المياه
لجميع السكان